[Music]
in conspiracy or truth news submitted by
I love mafia me to wonder if my mafia
again aviation experts are now
suggesting that the Malaysia Airlines
flight 370 crash was deliberate mmm no
[ __ ]
I think I'm an ocean is that the first
one of the second one first you know I
had an interesting conversation with the
uber driver of mine because he's going
to become a pilot and yeah there was a
lot of information that he told me but
he was tell me all these stories about
like how Asian countries have a certain
like chain of command type of thing I
think we went over this but there was
like a really famous flight in Japan
where I was like Japan air and they had
to go through like a whole company
revamp because when they were the the
pilot was gonna commit suicide with the
whole plane oh you know the people other
people that are with them the other
pilot people they knew of it but because
the chain of command they wouldn't say
anyway and so they allowed him to commit
suicide and kill everybody on the plane
yeah didn't want to speak out of time
wait were they on the plane yes they
were on the plane
what and they knew that he was gonna
commit suicide so he was telling me this
story cuz like Korea had something
similar to that but I guess Japan was
like even worse than that because they
knew of the suicide attempt damn
so flopping on the chain of command was
more serious than dying yeah that makes
sense
yeah that that makes sense it's pretty
insane death crane like yeah cuz like
Korea had the thing where the guy was
like [ __ ] up or whatever and he didn't
want to say something or someone thing
and they survived but the plane crashed
or whatever some [ __ ] like that yeah
that's crazy yeah it might be an older
generation - did that happen like not
recently
it's like 80s or 70s or whatever it was
a while back okay ya know cuz culturally
it makes sense why in Japan they they
respect a chain on there is like order
yeah it's just sometimes they're so
robotic cuz you're drilled with the
whole hierarchy system and not speaking
out of line since like a baby
so you it's really hard for them to you
know there's a human side where it's
like there's human morals like yeah you
survived
all right but then there's the other
side where it's like they just they
can't act like a human I think they'd
rather die obeying the rules then to the
being ashamed a you couldn't live up to
the system yeah I like the color
yeah it's pretty it's pretty crazy it's
different now though it probably won't
fly now but it's pretty still extreme if
you compare it to American standards
yeah so now investigators are still
searching for the aircraft that still
hasn't been found but they have found
like pieces here and there and so now
they're saying that it seems like the
captain he was he pretty much killed him
so I like it was like a suicide mm-hmm
because he was flying along the border
of Malaysia and Thailand he deliberately
flew to that the place of where it
disappeared which was about another 115
miles more than experts originally
thought and so there there was this one
moment where the wing dipped over the
captains home like home hometown town
yeah it was that great hometown oh my
gosh I couldn't be so you could see it
yes it was kind of like a goodbye like
that's what they're saying that it was
kind of a goodbye it was a captain how
did they find out this information
I'm so happy I really don't know they're
just like I thought the black box that
each plane has I don't think he's
recovered but the black box didn't say
it like they dipped his wing you know
like how did they find that out yeah I
mean it's kind of vague there could be
like records of flight pattern and maybe
it would like flight patterns yeah
because they were saying that the reason
why he was flying along the borders of
Malaysia and Thailand it's because like
Oh like both countries there they're
really hands-off because like oh it's
not in my air spacing anymore I'm not
gonna pay attention to where it's flying
anymore so then that's how he what they
would have liked so you kind of knew
that no one was [ __ ] with that area
mm-hmm
well I bet you have like co-pilots and
other people around you think no one was
like hey
wait a minute we don't know like that's
why it's a speculation Shifu not take a
[ __ ]
well what's wrong with no you need to
get the Bunga s-- malaysian food yes
maybe you got the Bunga still taking
shingles this is my chance to make the
plane disappear flew six hours out of
his way to do this but lost my
conviction there's what they're saying
so obviously we're never gonna know 100%
what exactly happened because this
captain he had his own clan know what's
weird to me though is like the
back-to-back missing plane yeah it is
like they it's like they kind of
answered one I guess it could be
deliberate and suicide but then what
about the other one
like right it's like within the same
month or some [ __ ] - is Malaysian air
still around yeah I think it still
operates yeah okay I thought they went
out of business I don't really like
Malaysian there I like any Asian airline
except for like some Chinese ones oh wow
southern don't do that one ooh Chinese
airlines are I don't know man China air
was bomb like the actual like ride was
great but the food was awful
Marial gots like some deal to go to
Japan for like 400 bucks right but she
had to go through some which I thought
it was probably the worst Chinese
airline ever she said it was the worst
flight experience of her life Wow don't
fly air china don't fly China southern
China Airlines is actually colonies air
is the one that I took I should be okay
yeah it was okay every time Air China
China Southern is not good I remember
going to the gate I was even flying it
but I saw China Southern this the flight
staff come the [ __ ] pilot had his hat
turned this way one of his thus the
bottom sleeves of his dress shirt is
popping out like he just had a rough
drinking night just based off a parents
alone on my if this wasn't a dress like
this imagine I was gonna fly the plane
I'm like [ __ ] that dang yeah what if he
just wants a chill vibe on his plane
hello everybody good luck to you that's
what he says good luck good night and
oh yeah okay good luck
my favorite is Singapore yeah
Singapore is great I love that course oh
nice
dude I flew of Singapore Airlines to
Singapore in coach and it was amazing
really yeah
I flew both coach and business and I
like both but yes it's dope yeah dude
one thing though I will say this
probably a big the biggest benefit of
losing weight was when I went on the
flight and I wasn't as uncomfortable
that's time like if you're a big person
like why do I it is the most
uncomfortable thing being in a plane and
that was the one thing that I could not
[ __ ] stand it's like if I make I knew
for a fact I was spilling over
everywhere so so I would just meet you
both of you and this guy spills
everywhere to you you know the in the
[ __ ] mouth huh and now I actually
enjoy going being in the aisle seat now
like the aisle seat versus being in the
window just because like now I know I'm
not so obtrusive to this side but I
don't feel as claustrophobic so I now I
instead of going through the window seat
I now go over to the aisle seat there
this isn't I'll give you more room yeah
but then I I'd like the window see
because I could just lean over as far as
possible cuz I didn't want to get in
anybody's way about them I just go one
way on the window with this well I feel
like I'm like bothering like the
stewardess and everything else so and I
didn't want to crush this person over
here - so I just rather just sit in the
window and then lean away just to make
it more comfortable that is nice I was
just on a 16-hour flight with this huge
dude and this was in business class and
so like you're supposed to have a lot
more space he just didn't give a [ __ ] he
put his arms like all the way onto my
side like in spilling into my chair and
everything and then he fell asleep that
way and he was breathing snoring at me
like oh my last a Southwest flight there
was there was like literally two seats
left in the back both middle ones right
and I I boarded to the back so you could
board two places in Burbank read the
board from the back of the front I
bought it from the back I went to the
last seat right because I could give a
[ __ ] less what time I get off the plane
- middle seats left the biggest guy
comes up all I said to him was like come
on bro come on he look he was like I
he's like oh well
you sit next to me man we're the two
biggest [ __ ] on the plane it's
not good for you or me yeah second guess
what you're doing wrong come on
yeah he felt a sense of Crowe moderate
camaraderie like hey he didn't really
think it through yeah I was like come on
dude like we would just all been super
uncomfortable it just wouldn't have
worked out well for anybody because I
was big and the person on the other side
was also big - it's like - Jesse it was
like oh yes an Asian pillow we all just
suffer together it's like going to
school that way dude - skinny little
ladies just sit in between them you know
I flew Thai Airlines they have good food
hoots - would be good Korean Airlines is
cool you ever start booking planes by
their their cultures food yeah their
food is good the air was the worst food
I've ever had I was I just took
Philippine Airlines which was the food
was good but what was it they had you
got a selection so you could do you
could do seafood you could do the only
thing was didn't how many vegetarian
choices so I had to do seafood what did
you get for seafood like shrimp and does
it taste
Filipino no cuz it was like the one was
a Filipino dish one was an Asian dish
and one was a American dish and so the
seafood one was always I've never choose
the American one I never want to Korean
Air's stewardess are really nice and
they're really pretty really nice and if
you're in the double that girl one in
your oh yeah I saw their outfits yeah
cuz they were right next to Philippine
Airlines super [ __ ] you like the
Britney Spears music video yeah yeah
yeah when we were in the plane I guess
like I have like a very typically Korean
ass [ __ ] face and so yeah you know my
Korean is way worse than Mario's release
in there and my Korean is my formal
Korean sucks but they just kept speaking
to Mariel in English and they would look
at me and always speak to me in Korean
even if I'm talking to me well you look
super Korean though because every time
we watch like a Korean movie on that
place this is like why does everyone
look like David yeah you the way you
part your hair even
it's accordion-style you know it's a
pretty good one too Qantas Qantas is
[ __ ] dull if you could if you're ever
gonna go to Australia fly the Qantas man
dude
New Zealand air they they like have all
their New Zealand wines and they just
like come by and sample you all their
wines the whole time trying to get you a
jar on tight I'll have to play Norwegian
so that's the worst airline sorry no HF
it is no there they treat you like they
don't give a [ __ ] what you live you live
or die just like ma I didn't I didn't
fly business but in coach they wouldn't
even bring water and you couldn't even
get like a person like at all so like if
you're just feeling turbulence did you
see the Stewart's go stop being [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they walk by and I guess like you have
to pre order your meals that this is in
coach
like you have to pre order your meals
but it wasn't very they didn't say that
in the email like they didn't like
really make that clear
so a few people I guess knew to
pre-order their meals and so they'd go
right to those people give them a meal
and water and whatever they would even
look at you they'd go right over your
stomach and you're like nope nope
they're gone and so you had to go a 10
hour flight this was from Europe to back
to America and he was like a 10-hour
flight without any water will be so cool
no they're [ __ ] is it a budget
airline I don't know but it happened
both going there and coming back so it
wasn't just a fluke like oh yeah did you
preorder your meals what we're fine
business so I've got a double check girl
cuz I've never even heard of that for
Colleen either yeah
terrible no food no water no you pick it
was part of the options of the only was
it business but it only cost $200 cousin
that's a funny [ __ ] signal it was
more than that $50 for a business
[Music]
[Music]